et
[Musique]
madame candy données l'auteur s'est
donné quoi le nom d'auteur
[Musique]
j'entendais téléphone sonne et vous
savez très bien que c'est interdit au
collège en plus en évaluation le
prochain que j'attrape je garde le
téléphone simon cote ou ca trù verglas
et ce six où ça mange il existe cacher
non loin des toits leur set ultime
turgot 6
rebonds
il est arrivé à bombay tuant béland
[Musique]
messieurs là le monstre du loch ness
heroes dit si tu es vraiment telga
arrêtera comme un pote cauet dont allons
vérifier
tiennent entre les dolotières
rien il n'y aura pas la viande et le
monstre mais sur les photos
[Applaudissements]
et
pas
[Musique]
maladroit c'est que
nous dépensons trop vous trouvez pas que
c'est génial tout s'est sentie sur notre
île ouais mais c'est dommage je les
trouvais ça
c'est bien ça me dégoûte les gens ne
respectent pas l'environnement
[Applaudissements]
bof tout ça court ça c'est jacques un
morceau de cartes ouais mais vous me la
daad est quand même assez fermé
[Musique]
ça vient de trouver c'est très populaire
ça fait trois semaines pour la recherche
et pee wee à prouver
[Musique]
tout ça pour ça aucune idée sur mon jeu
et aucun commentaire hier il n'y a même
pas la recette bon en même temps on a
appris des choses sur notre vie par
exemple le prête minot a construit cette
église de ses propres mains et c'est en
1810 on a appris aussi que cette église
a été rénové par le père et beau en 1900
les vraies menaces qui planent à passer
à la halle a ralenti les travaux idées
appelle jenny c'est bien tout ça mais là
on en 2022
en gros on se retrouve avec une carte
on aurait peut-être juste devant les
deux lada nos camarades vous avez raison
peut-être que tout n'est pas perdu et
ils sont où mais quelque chose de leur
côté
je suis déjà fatigué au bien commun à
ces
trois
axes et c'est parce qu'il avait
tout
d'un coup qu'on va se passer
à dakar est rodé puisqu'il faut
j'étais mathis sa fille cachée de la
gamme a bien aidé à bata shoe
partagez vos motos à caissargues à
moteur
bon moteur il a fait ce papier sont
retrouvées ce pesca
ni bourbon paris ouvrent là voie pas
made man who du combat baril non plus de
quitter sans toi
quoique souvent mon patron
m'a tenus mais je dois comment vois tu
oublies même un jour
pour des taux
communaux
saga
[Musique]
on a tous et fausse route on a tous été
égoïste chacun a cherché de son côté et
maintenant grâce à samuel et mathis on
sait que si on s'unit tous on trouvera
la recette ultime du rougail saucisses
si vous êtes tous d'accord déposez votre
morceau de kart
wii on met la même heure samedi au
niveau
[Musique]
c'est quand même fou qu'aujourd'hui on
partage plus rien on vit tous de notre
côté la société est tellement
individualiste on passe toute la journée
sur nos téléphones la preuve on partage
plus on n'est pas à chercher nos
recettes tout seul alors qu'on pouvait
le faire tous ensemble mais au final le
chômage sont quand même croisé mais
c'est peut-être ça le message de la
recette du rougail saucisse c'est
tellement émouvant que six venant
flirter en mai gaza
[Musique]
merci
où
[Musique]